[Musik]
wie gott ihn und ihre frau serafin wenig
schlafen und am ende des lebens beginnt
ihre arbeit palliativpflege fachfrau
livia depot wird ein krebskrankes
ehepaar besuchen sie sind beide sehr
erschöpft kaufmann wird stabil schlacht
sind sie wird mit dieser am tisch sitzt
wird dieser verzeichnen
herr kaufmann bin im moment unsicher wo
das noch in wäre da treffe wählerisch
bekräftigte tagtäglich am verschlechtern
[Musik]
seit 50 jahren ist das ehepaar kaufmann
verheiratet
der krebs wird sie bald trennen ernst
kaufmann hat heute seine frau etwas zu
sein hat es da oder dort keine würde das
geschäft machen oder aber ziemlich blöd
ich weiß aber dass wir es könnten oder
der 74 jährige will ins spital zu
sterben
es ist eine entscheidung der vernunft
trotzdem ruft wolle nicht dass er
wirklich sehr sehr gefasst sind beide
und das war jetzt passiert ist normal
und darf weil man verliebt ist nur auf
dem 7
jetzt haben wir diese woche verkauft und
wurde mit einer offen
ihr hobby ist das fertigen von lebens
echt aussehenden barbies allein bis sie
die haare aus baumwolle eingezogen hat
braucht sie 100 stunden
es bringt den kaufmann leidet an
brustkrebs leberkrebs sowie einer
schweren lungenkrankheit für die 74
jährige kommt eine chemotherapie nicht
mehr in frage
im zimmer nebenan die wir die toffel
hört die dam geräusche von ernst
kaufmann ab ihre patienten und
patientinnen sollen so lange wie möglich
zu hause bleiben können das ist ihr ziel
zwei wochen später stirbt ernst kaufmann
im spital in liga der top job braucht es
bewusste momente des innehaltens im büro
der stiftung palliativer gibt es zu
diesem zweck eine kleine gedenkstätte
mit den todesanzeigen der patientinnen
und patienten
der pflegeberuf ist ein anspruchsvolles
wechselspiel zwischen nähe und distanz
abgrenzung ist wichtig dass ich meinen
job und dankbar bin froh dass ich einmal
beteiligung und mich eingelassen haben
und das auch so kann immer wieder gut
begleitet in dem dass sie es mit jedem
kilometer den livia detailliert wird
über spenden finanziert sie besucht
täglich etwa vier patienten ihr auto ist
ein mini spital in auf rädern alles
mögliche für interventionen material
alles für ihre geschwächten patientinnen
und patienten ist es eine erleichterung
wenn die medizinische versorgung zu
ihnen nach hause kommt
chancenlos hat lungenkrebs mit hirn
metastasen der musikproduzent wäre fast
gestorben
ich glaube nicht dass ich für mich keine
chance und sie es mit medizinischer
hilfe und gott liga total kontrolliert
heute seinen blutdruck kopiert gemacht
sie misst die sauerstoffsättigung und
klebt dem 71-jährigen ein neues morphin
pflaster zur schmerzlinderung auf alle
unheilbar kranken menschen haben das
anrecht auf eine palliativversorgung die
pflege kann dabei durchaus jahre dauern
so wie im fall von chancenlos er macht
eine immuntherapie gegen seinen krebs
livia der torf spielt seinen dauer
katheter damit es nicht zu infektionen
kommt
dann sagt ingo flasche galt
bei der diagnose lungenkrebs letztes
jahr war sein körper voll mit tumoren
dank der immuntherapie schöpfen er und
seine familie nun neue hoffnung ist
glaube hajo 20 jahre mit sowie in zürich
oerlikon erwartet sie ein büro tag von
hier aus organisiert die stiftung palais
aviva ihre rund um die uhr einsätze für
den grossraum zürich
heute trifft sich das team für das
monatliche die briefing supervision
trotz vollem einsatz kann nur ein
drittel ihrer patientinnen und patienten
zu hause sterben
das hinterlässt manchmal gefühle des
versagens wahrheit weder die hype lieben
und es plötzlich oder sie im spital und
was ich da passiert das ist ja ganz
häufig unser alltag wir kommen in
situation viel zu spät das ist beim
reinkommen schon unser erster gedanke zu
spät wir hätten viel mehr erreichen
können wenn wir früher drin gewesen sind
und das macht viel aus sterben zu hause
braucht vorbereitung für alle ist klar
sie möchten mit ihrem fachwissen
möglichst früh mit einbezogen werden
seit dem letzten besuch bei kaufmanns
sind drei wochen vergangen
die welt von marion kaufmann ist in
dieser zeit eine andere geworden
ihr mann ernst verstarb vor einer woche
morgen wird madeleine kaufmann ihren
mann beerdigen
zugleich rückt ihr eigenes sterben eher
sie will keine lebensverlängernden
maßnahmen zusammen mit der
pflegefachfrau hat sie ihre wünsche für
den medizinischen notfall in einer
patientenverfügung zusammengefasst in
ihrem privatleben sucht die mutter
zweier teenager entschleunigung und ruhe
oft mit balu der mischlingshund ist
blind taub und nicht mehr so schnell auf
den beinen
dies ist sein letzter sommer wie für
viele ihrer patienten loslassen
das kann sie
xbox spiel gar keine angst warum sterben
auch nicht vor dem sterben
einerseits bin ich weit davon entfernt
im moment andererseits kann ich es so so
viel man erlebt und dementsprechend
wahrscheinlich auch nicht so
abschreckend erlebt dass sie mein team
ist seit 20 jahren schaut sie dem tod in
seiner vielen gesichter
lang hat das meter studierens lieder
schreibt liebe lieder so sieht einig sie
fasste meine frau lang ihre wünsche sind
so lange wie möglich eine gute
lebensqualität
die 49 jährige patientin ist unheilbar
krebskranker die mutter zweier kinder
hat darmkrebs nur lang ist schon seit
einem jahr in chemotherapie
ich habe mich heute jetzt an diesen
besseres vor zwei tage lang über die so
übel musste er abbrechen
die pflegefachfrau hängt der ich lerne
ganze kennen nur lang ist froh muss sie
zum abhängen des medikaments nicht ins
spital
sie ist müde ihr darmkrebs hat ableger
auf leber und lunge gemacht ja das
glaube ich
jaja befreit ja der schwerkraft frei ihr
leben ist klein geworden aber nur lang
beklagt sich nicht
was für sie jetzt zählt ist ihre familie
wenn die kinder mein mann so wirklich
atmosphäre haben im haus dann bin ich
schon glücklich
seit dem letzten besuch bei madame
kaufmanns in fünf wochen vergangen ihre
erwachsenen kinder möchten für sie nun
eine haushaltshilfe
die wir einmal in der woche lang auf
hilfe
ich sehe das wie rechteckig oder das
richtig durch vorstellen geht nicht mehr
sie ist schwach geworden seit dem
frühling hat madeleine kaufmann 30 kilo
verloren
ihr körper ist voll mit tumoren in der
brust auf der leber
sie denkt an ihren mann der vor kurzem
an krebs gestorben ist
sehr gern geschehen bis zum nächsten
ihre kappen
[Musik]
gemacht hatte frau albracht ein patent
in chronischen calida hat copd
und wo wir schon länger so sind betreut
die liebe hat maria albrecht als junge
frau von finnland in die schweiz
gebracht
heute ist sie witwe wegen ihres
lungenleidens braucht sie tag und nacht
sauerstoff ihr leben hängt an einem
schlauch irgendwie immer denkt als
modell der trotzdem
es beruhigt die 69 jährige dass sie im
medizinischen notfall tag und nacht die
dienste der palliativ spitex in anspruch
nehmen kann
wie werdet obwohl fährt zu den
hinterbliebenen eines 62-jährigen daheim
sterben geht nur wenn die familie das
trägt
sie hat sehr beeindruckt die musikreihe
untereinander als barbara als dritter
als familie und das die das mittel amt
und direkt stand der wunsch vom herz
aller macht mit dem schluss der
freiheitsliebe die 18-jährige suleika
zähler zeigt die todesanzeige armin
zelle starb vor fünf monaten qualvoll an
leberkrebs
die heimat stirbt ja ich finde entwurf
und moralischen druck
und das ganz ganz weit weg sind
es ist mitte august auf dem friedhof in
dübendorf besucht man den kaufmann mit
ihrer schwägerin das grab ihres mannes
der krebs hat sie aufgezehrt sie denkt
an die regeln es sterben ihren letzten
wunsch traute sich kaum zu äußern
zwei wochen später halten ihr die kinder
beim sterben die hand ihre asche kommt
hierher zurück
es ist herbst geworden
wie werdet oft in ihrem garten die
letzten feigen
niemand wisse was ihm sterben auf ihn
zukomme das tier wog nur krank und sich
mit der krankheit mit dem sterben vor
allem mit dem dass man endlich sind
auseinander und ruhiger sie hat
hunderten menschen dabei geholfen vom
leben loszulassen
[Musik]
ich finde es immer wieder erstaunlich
wie ihr mentor koch und menschen
begleite lebenskünstler sind und sich
immer wieder versuchen sich immer wieder
versuchen einen neuen situation ein
neues leiter neue defizite immer weniger
wo man haben hunderte roma wo einfacher
gemacht hat dass man immer mehr verliert
und trotzdem im widder und wechselt zum
zum mitklatschen
einer sitzt und dann besitz der visa
card blick ins leben
[Musik]